Welcome To The Sky News Daily I'm Neil
Patterson
Boris Johnson is a liar no I hasten to
add those are not my words but those of
Mr Johnson's former colleagues in
Parliament the psychodrama that is
Westminster politics emphasis on drama
well it's just taken another dramatic
turn the Privileges committee that's the
group of MPS that's been looking into
Boris Johnson's Behavior they have now
finally published their report and look
given that the former prime minister was
given advance site of the report and
then immediately announced his intention
to resign but you didn't have to be a
political Editor to assume that it
didn't make for great reading but now
that we've all had time to go through
the report in detail it is perhaps even
more damning than anyone had expected
and Boris Johnson says he doesn't accept
a word of it
so what did the committee actually
conclude and is this the end of the
political Ambitions of the man who told
his eaten counterparts that he wanted to
be World King those are the questions
we'll be asking on this edition of The
Daily
well who better to speak to on an
occasion such as this than Sky's
political editor Beth Rigby Beth just
run us through exactly what has this
report concluded and it must have been
so so damning because of course Boris
Johnson through his political career and
his toys at the pram last week yeah look
Neil it's all falling into place now
isn't it what happened on Friday when
Boris Johnson shot tuzzle with this
resignation ahead of the committee
report coming out basically saying it
was a political stitch up this was a
kangaroo court when you look at the
report it's far more damning than
perhaps was expected the sanction that
would have been laid upon him had he
still been an MP was a recommendation
for a 90-day suspension even his
harshest critics were not expecting such
a punishing sanction and in terms of the
conclusions near well look it said that
he deliberately misled the house
deliberately misled the committee
breached confidence that he undermined
the Democratic process of the house and
he was complicit in the campaign of
abuse and intented intimidation of the
committee they also recommended that
they should take his parliamentary pass
away from him uh they say that basically
throughout the process Boris Johnson
made it worse for himself in terms of
the sanction because they say in uh
they're concluding remarks they said
that they were going to provisionally
recommend a suspension long enough to
engage the provisions of the recall of
MPS at that base it means suspend them
for 10 days or more in order to allow
his constituents should they so desire
to trigger a by-election by a petition
basically of a certain number of Voters
you can trigger a by-election so they
wanted to give his constituents that
choice but they then say in the light of
Mr Johnson's further contempts we put on
record that if he had not resigned his
seat we would have recommended that he
be suspended from the south of the house
for 90 days for repeated contempts and
by further contempts you are directly
referencing the fact that Boris Johnson
was given Advanced sight of this
committee's report and then decided
rather than waiting for it to be
published and submitting his response to
the committee that he'd submit it
publicly exactly I interviewed Jacob
Brie smoke about this and I said do you
not think that was an appalling breach
of confidence now his rebuttal
um was that Boris Johnson didn't release
the details of the report but look I
mean when he said I've got no option but
to resign for now how heavily loaded
were those two words you know we all
knew well that means that they were
going to suspend you so we knew at that
point that even though he hadn't
explicitly said it the fact that he was
going to be sanctioned in this way meant
that they had you know found against him
quite heavily I mean look the fact is
Neil that when they started the hearings
they said it they thought it was very
likely that he had misled the house just
on that part on that point bet just
explain misleading the house and lying
it's one of these weird parliamentary
conventions that you don't you don't
describe someone as a lie it's kind of
parliamentary parlance if you like you
don't describe someone as a liar
although interestingly in the house
today a labor MP did just outright call
Boris Johnson a liar so it's about
misleading the house now
look
politicians do sometimes mislead the
house it might be the dust batch box
that they say something that's
inaccurate or untrue the point is that
if you correct the record that is
acceptable the issue here is did Boris
Johnson mislead the house with
statements about guidance and rules
being followed in number 10 during
lockdowns when it emerged that they
weren't did he deliberately mislead the
house and his argument was always I did
mislead the house because there were
breaches but I thought it was all in the
guidelines so I didn't deliberately
mislead the house but at the heart of
his case has always been this idea that
he received repeated assurances that the
events that were taking place in
particularly the events that he was
attending that they were legal and of
course everyone asked the question time
and time again Who provided that
Assurance now I haven't gone through
this report with a fine tooth comb
rather wider comb actually but I can't
find a single piece of evidence that
suggests that Boris Johnson named Anyone
Who provided those assurance and
actually I I was looking through the
report on this and the point that the
MPS make from the committee was that
I've got it here this is on page 71 the
impression the house would have taken
would have been intended to take from
Johnson's repeated references to
assurances that these assurances have
been overarching and comprehensive and
to be given great weight in fact as we
have seen the only assurances that we
can be certain were given to Mr Johnson
were arrived at in-house based on a
press line to take so press officers
basically he was behaving legally not a
lawyer not the cabinet secretary yeah no
permanent secretary exactly and the
point would be MPS would say when you go
to the House of Commons you should be
armed with the facts and assurances from
your comms team is not the same as an
assurance from your permanent secretary
or very senior uh civil servant but I
also think Neil that really what the
committee came back to was the fact that
given that Boris Johnson was the Prime
Minister that he had been responsible
for the rules and the guidance that was
put in place and that he had been at
these events that he would have seen
with his own eyes in their words that
rules were being broken so I think the
whole premise of his defense really you
know you read this report and it's clear
that the committee never really believed
it in the first place perhaps even more
egregious than than the idea that these
repeated assurances came from you know
none other than a couple of very Junior
civil servants it's the idea that the
committee puts forward that that Boris
Johnson was himself rewriting the rules
you know post-hoc to suit himself that
the idea that that he and everyone else
in number 10 were absolutely certain of
the fact that leaving dues to the store
morale within the Downing Street
environment were within the rules but
that was never my impression of what the
rules were it certainly wasn't the
impression you know if other colleagues
it certainly wasn't the impression that
other friends took about this yeah so I
mean in the in the bundle of evidence
there's a sort of very tasty bit from a
uh number 10 official in which they say
that wine time Fridays uh took place
that these were calendared weekly events
that they continued throughout lockdowns
that there was not much enforcement or
rather they were slow to enforce any
rules in the building social distancing
was not enforced it says here number 10
was like an island oasis of normality it
was part of the wider culture of knotted
hearing to any rules and that birthday
parties leaving parties end of week
Gatherings all continued as normal
and it says here those responsible for
the leadership of number 10 failed to
keep it to Safe space and should have
set rules from the start now you know we
don't know who that piece of evidence is
from and we know that there were many
axes to grind within Boris Johnson's
number 10 but I think also near what
that does is it speaks to a culture
which of course we have seen that
culture because of you know the 120 plus
fixed penalty notices that the
Metropolitan Police issued around
government around lots of different
events that occurred during lockdowns
and I think that that was a very
Illuminating piece of evidence about the
cultural inside Boris Johnson's number
10. it isn't his birthday party the the
kind of the clearest example of that I
mean the committee concluded that his
claims about the the party were not
convincing that that he Mr Johnson the
Prime Minister the man in charge of
these covered rules and regulations
he believed it was perfectly proper for
officials to come and wish him a very
happy birthday the committee also
pointed out they somehow believed that
having his wife and his interior
designer that they were both absolutely
necessary participants in a business
meeting I mean that is a that's a
perfect example of what you're talking
about isn't it and I mean that was the
one event out of all of these things
that he dropped in on or walked through
or gave a short speech at or whatever it
was that birthday party was the event
where he was issued with a fixed penalty
notice as was the current prime minister
Rishi sunak who arrived in the room I
think there was going to be another
meeting in that room and they were both
fined for that I I imagine I'm trying to
get into the head of Boris Johnson here
that it was his home and it was his
workplace and he maybe thought this is
what he argued at the committee that it
was a work event now it was clearly a
celebration with a cake and drinks which
at the time everyone else in the country
were told uh that they they couldn't do
I think the point of all of this Neil if
you sort of zoom out from the detail of
the report is that Boris Johnson has
left Parliament sort of lobbing grenades
back in at his opponents and at the
current prime minister
insisting that he told the truth he
didn't intentionally mislead Parliament
he genuinely thought these were work
events the committee has concluded that
they simply think that that is untenable
and not believable given that he was
present at things before his very eyes
that would have been to any reasonable
person as they put it breaches of the
rule rules I think the big question in
all of this Neil is once you kind of
read through the report and it kind of
smacks you around the Headroom I mean
it's so critical of him is does it
change the political weather for him
and you know reading it and talking to
people today it sort of seems like those
who were critical of Boris Johnson this
just gives them more grits to their meal
justification of why he should be
criticized which I get but presumably
the number of people who are queuing up
to defend Boris Johnson is not quite as
long as it once was well
say that but I was going to say that the
flip side is this report also doesn't
necessarily change the mind of those
people that believe he's been unfairly
attacked and actually if anything
certainly what sir Jacob Reese monk said
to me today and what others have said to
me is the fact that they've recommended
this 90-day sanction Which is far more
extreme than most people expecting kind
of gives them wind in their sales to
argue that this is overreach that this
is a political agenda by the committee
so I what I actually feel at the moment
and let's see how it shakes out Neil is
that this report basically entrenches
both positions yeah yeah it just creates
more heat not light if you like because
both sides feel justified in their
Viewpoint and in in hardening those
divisions it makes it harder for Rishi
sunak to sort of paper over the visions
and and bring back this fragile peace in
the party and I think when Penny Morden
the leader of the commons uh stood up to
talk about the vote that's going to
happen on Monday when she said this is
sad and painful she said I would urge
all colleagues to actually read the
report carefully and then think about
how you are going to vote it's a free
vote they can vote with their conscience
and then she said you know and I would
ask that all of us are left alone to do
that I.E can we stop being pressured it
speaks to the fact that there is huge
pressure amongst colleagues about how
they're going to vote are you going to
back Boris or not bat Boris and then
there will be huge pressure from
constituents because in a way Neil this
is a sort of parliamentary verdict on
Boris Johnson which has effectively
kicked him out of Westminster
but as for a political combat whether
this really is the end of Boris
Johnson's political career I I think
it's still unclear because those that
really have very little time for him
they'll just think that this reassures
them of how they feel and those that
support him will think that this is
further evidence that this Committee in
the end became politicized and went for
him well let's see who the public
believes the Privileges committee or
Boris Johnson Beth I don't know about
you but I'm about ready for wine time
Friday so I'm going to let you go first
time Friday yeah I think it's trebles
all around thanks very much pleasure
[Music]
other thanks to our esteemed political
editor Beth Rigby this Edition was
produced by Rosie Gillett our editor is
Paul stanworth